Hi
I am an advocate of Dan Galpin Android development.
Let's talk about the preview of Android 7.1 here.
A few weeks ago
We tell everyone the Android 7.1 developer preview
Will be released soon
If you don't know it, it is now released.
Preview and other versions
There are some differences
Version 7.1 has been released on Pixel
We released the original developer preview
Test on Nexus devices
The goal is to find any device-related issues
In other words, we have already API
Set to API level 25 and we publish open source on Google Play
Easy application development for new API versions
So you can update your app as soon as possible
What new features are there?
First Android 7.1 startup
There are several changes
Apply shortcuts to allow you to be a key action in your app
Add static and dynamic links
Users just have to press and hold your app launch icon
To display app shortcuts
Then click on the shortcut to start the relevant action
Every shortcut has an intent
Each will initiate a specific action or task
You can create shortcuts for any operation
You can express it as an intention
For example, your creation intention can be
Send new information to make an appointment
Play video to continue the game loading map location
and many more
You can statically add shortcuts to your app.
Resource files in the APK by adding them
You can also add them dynamically at runtime.
Static shortcuts for normal operations
Dynamic shortcuts let you
Emphasize the operation according to the user's preferences
Behavioral location, etc.
You can create five shortcuts in every application.
When you add a shortcut to your app
Can be accessed by supporting their launch bar
For example, the default launch bar on the Pixel boot bar Pixel device
Now Launcher default launch bar on Nexus devices
And other support bars that provide support
Any application can create shortcuts
Any startup bar app can support shortcuts
Android 7.1 provides an API for the app
To register shortcuts and launch bar
To access the registered shortcuts
The application can now define the loop launch bar icon
Devices that can be used to support them
Most of these are happening automatically
When launching to request an app icon
You can receive the Android icon
Or Android round icon
According to the configuration of the device
You can use Image Asset Studio to design round icons
You can test your round icon on a Google Pixel device
Or use the Google API's emulation system to run the Android emulator
For API level 25
Related to the launch bar
Is to strengthen the metadata of the wallpaper
In addition to existing metadata attributes
Such as label description and author
There are a lot of new properties about context links and headlines
Link user to
More information about wallpapers
This allows for a better and richer user experience
When choosing a live wallpaper
Another Android 7.1 feature is to make stickers and other rich content.
Via soft keyboard
Also called input method editor or IME
7.1 SDK includes Commit Content API
It provides a general way to send information
And other content
a text editor sent directly to the app via an IME
API also has revision 25 version
In the support library of V13
With this API you can build information applications
Come to receive rich information from any keyboard
You can also use the keyboard to send rich information to any app.
There are two more in the 7.1 version.
Cool features you might want to take advantage of
The first is the storage manager's intent
The storage manager's intent that the application can now trigger an action
Bring the user to the system's Free Up Space interface
If your app needs more space than there is now
It can use this intent to let users delete unwanted apps
And content to get enough space
Another feature you can take advantage of with your app is
Check if the device is running
Demo user using new user manager
Is a way to demonstrate users
This makes your app customizable
Initial experience of potential customers
Run the app as a demo user
Apps will give users more help
Or more carefully explain its function
There are many new features in the 7.1 release.
Such as supporting a larger resolution
And some important phone features
Please visit developer.android.com to view the Android 7.1 page.
To get more information
If you have already joined the Android test project
Your registered device
Will now receive Android 7.1
Developer Preview Update
You don't need to do anything
If you have not registered to join the Android test group
You can register by visiting Android.com/beta
Choose your eligible Android phone or tablet
You will receive it soon
Preview update
If you have a registered device
But don't want to receive this update, you only need to access Android Beta.
Cancel registration of this device
You can also manually download this update from the flash drive.
We welcome you in the Developer Preview issue tracker
Leave feedback in the preview developer community and the Android test community
We are working hard to release the user version in December.